hi beanie how are you hi i'm good how
are you i'm great i mean i'm loving i
remember interviewing you for book smart
and now you're here having this moment
how does it feel for you to be taking on
this character of a leading lady but not
just a leading lady but kind of letting
this lady lead her own way for the first
time by involving monica in the story
yeah um that's really beautiful way of
putting it she's leading her way for the
first time it's con honestly one of the
greatest honors i've ever had certainly
as an actress it is the most i've ever
been pushed the most i've ever deeply
deeply cared because it is not just a
story but it's a real woman story and a
woman that i love and that i care about
and that i text
you know so it is um honestly the
greatest honor of my whole life has been
to get to portray her on screen and give
her back to the world and retell her
story um it's it's been surreal in every
way mr president do you know a woman
named monica lewinsky that's me that's
my face what did you and monica text
each other today ahead of this evening
we didn't text today but we texted
yesterday about what color we were
wearing um but we honestly we we sent
you know the app marco polo yeah we sent
each other videos on marco polo and
we're just pals we're really pals at
this point and at the beginning right
before we started shooting i said to
monica i just want you to know that you
are my bodyguard i am your bodyguard i
will protect you
i will put my body in front of your body
and and and
and give your story back to the world
and it really meant a lot to me that she
was a part of it and for the first time
i think this woman's story that
everybody thinks they understand they
only knew a late night joke or a
caricature or a voice on a tape they
don't know the real woman behind it and
i think we're gonna
show that not for just for monica but
for linda tripp and for paula jones as
well so did you color coordinate and how
did you pick this dress um this dress
was chosen for me by my stylist erin
walsh she just had a beautiful baby boy
so she wasn't there today when i got
ready she literally just had her baby um
but i actually haven't seen what
monica's wearing so okay
well knowing her as well as you do what
is something that we all don't know
about monica lewinsky well you know
monica was not permitted to speak due to
her immunity deal with kenneth starr in
1998 1999 so she was literally silenced
so
i personally believe that the trauma and
the pain that she had to go through
during those two years is completely
unknown to the public if they do
understand it it's from a bullet point
or a quick
you know news story they don't
understand the deep humanity behind it
and so watching this woman go through
what she had to go through particularly
the hours that she was with um the
office of independent council and fbi
in the pentagon city mall i think will
really um
shock people and i hope
really illuminate what she was going
through what were the hardest scenes for
you to film certainly those um when
monica's
been
unbeknownst to her linda has led her to
the mall to be taken by the office of
independent council and the fbi and she
spends 11 hours in the ritz-carlton
hotel
um standing her ground and not
you know doing what they want her to do
which is to wear a wire and call the
president and it's a really remarkable
episode episode six and tell me about
the transformations yours looking into
the mirror becoming monica and also when
you saw clive owen as bill clinton and
sarah paulson as linda my mother did say
to me you look more beautiful as monica
so
she loved the transformation uh the wigs
are incredible i'll take that yeah i was
like i it's i only have my own hair i'm
sorry um but no she i she really it's
because i look more like her when i'm in
the in the wake um the wigs are
remarkable for me it was it was letting
my like my youth and my essence shine
through so it wasn't as much about
facial you know um
matching as much but for clivo and sarah
paulson when i first saw them on set i
was awestruck it's remarkable the
artistry of the prosthetics and the hair
and makeup and the wardrobe has has been
a you know ryan is so visually
remarkable in his work and i think
impeachment is a real the real pinnacle
of that ah well we can't wait for
everybody to see it really quick funny
girl we're so excited for that for you
next how's it going how are you
preparing uh you know we actually just
finished filming impeachment about 10
days ago so
i haven't gotten back to new york yet
but i will soon and i it's um my
childhood dream coming true so it's very
exciting
[Music]